welcome back let's do some more
derivative problems let's say I want to
figure out let's see I want to do the
derivative D over DX of and let me give
something that looks a little bit
different X to the 3rd minus 5x to the
fifth all of that to the let's say third
power over let's say it's over 2x plus
five to the fifth power this is a
parenthesis this is just saying that I
want to take the derivative of this
entire expression so you're saying Sal
we've never learned how to do this you
have something in the numerator you have
something in the denominator I don't
know what to do next well let's just
rewrite this they're actually in your in
your calculus textbooks or something
called the quotient rule which I think
is mildly lame because the quotient rule
is just the product rule where you have
where you have a negative exponent and
they make it another rule and they
clutter your brain so instead of using
the quotient rule we're just going to
rewrite this bottom expression as a
product and then we can use the product
rule so this is the same thing as taking
the derivative of X to the third minus
5x to the fifth all of that to the third
power times 2x plus five - what then
minus 5 power right and now we can use
the product rule take the derivative of
the first term and rid of the first term
isn't a joke you take the derivative of
the inside first let's do the chain rule
derivative at the inside first that is
3x squared minus 25 X to the fourth
times the derivative of the outside
three times this entire expression
X to the third minus five X to the fifth
and then all of that take this exponent
down 1/2 squared and then multiply it
times this whole term so two
X plus 5 to the minus 5 and then to that
we add the derivative of this term so
plus so the derivative of this term we
take the dirt at the inside which is
pretty easy it's just 2 times another
derivative of the outside which is minus
5 and just so you know I didn't skip a
step the derivative of 2x plus 5
derivative 2x is 2 derivative 5 is zero
so the derivative 2x plus 5 is just 2
this is 2 times minus 5 2x plus 5 right
we just keep that the same to the minus
5 power and then we multiply it times
this first expression X to the third
minus 5 X to the fifth
the third power I know that's really
messy and you're probably not see
problems this mess but I just wanted to
show you that that the product rule we
learned it's actually the product and
the chain rule they can apply to a lot
of different problems and even though
you haven't seen something like this
where he had a numerator denominator you
can easily rewrite what you had in the
denominator as a negative exponent and
then of course it's just the product for
when you don't have to memorize that
silly thing called the quotient rule so
with that out of the way I'm not gonna
introduce you to some common derivatives
of other functions and these things are
actually normally normally included in
the inside cover of your calculus book
and they're just good to know good good
things to know and maybe in a later
presentation I'll actually prove these
things you should never take things at
face value so these are you should to
some degree memorize these although you
should prove it to yourself first so the
derivative of e to the X and I find this
to be amazing e shows up all sorts of
crazy places in mathematics and it's you
know the strange number 2.7 whatever
whatever and it has all sorts of strange
properties and I think this is one of
the most bizarre properties of e the
derivative of e to the X if I want to
figure out the slope of any point along
the curve e to the X this just might
blow your mind I think the more you
think about it the more it'll blow your
mind is e to the X that's amazing at any
point along the curve e to the X the
slope of that point is
e to the X so if I said just just to hit
the point home I I'm diverting a little
bit but if I said f of X is equal to e
to the X right and let's say F of 2 is
equal to e squared right
and I asked you friend what is the slope
of e to the X at this point at the point
2 comma E squared and you could say Sal
the slope at that point is Yi squared
that blows my mind that it's a function
where the slope at any point on that
line is equal to the function and it's e
he shows up all sorts of places I mean I
might do a whole series of presentations
where called the magic of e because each
owes up all over the place I don't know
if you if you well I don't want to
diverge too much so that's pretty
amazing next I'm going to show you what
I think is probably the the second most
amazing derivative and I don't think
this has been fully explored in
mathematics yet because it this also
blows my mind is that the derivative of
the natural log of X right so the
natural log is just the logarithm with
base E and I hope you remember your
logarithms so what's the derivative of
the natural log of X so once again this
is ear elated well it's 1 over X that
also blows my mind right because think
about it let's draw a bunch of functions
if I said that the derivative of X to
the minus 3 is minus 3x to the minus 4
right
the derivative of X to the minus 2 is
minus 2x to the minus 3 right the
derivative of X to the minus 1 is minus
-1 X to the minus 2 the derivative of X
to the 0 well this is just 1 right the
derivative of X is X to 0 is just 1 so
the derivative is
zero the derivative of X is one
derivative of x squared is 2x and so on
right
so it's interesting we have this we have
this pattern right from all the
derivatives of all of the of kind of the
exponents in an increasing order where
you go from X to the minus four X to
minus three X to the minus two and then
there's no X to the minus one here right
and we go straight to X to the zero like
what happened - what happened to X to
the minus one right what happened to
this what functions derivative is X to
the minus one this is bizarre to me
where did it go and it turns out that
it's the natural log this I still think
about before I go to bed sometimes
because it is kind of mind-blowing so
and and later in another presentation I
might actually prove this to you but
just to know that this is true that the
derivative of the natural log of X is 1
over X I think is mind-blowing and so
for now you can just memorize it but
both of these are mind-blowing the
derivative of e to the X is e to the X
and the derivative of the natural log of
X is 1 over X and I'll just do a couple
of more just to present them to you and
then in the next presentation we'll
actually use them using the product rule
and the chain rule and etc etc and you
might want to re-watch this and memorize
them but let's see I want a clear image
image ok and and now I'll just do the
basic trig functions and these are you
should memorize these as well the
derivative of sine of X this is pretty
easy to remember it's cosine of X so the
slope at any point along the line sine
of X is actually the cosine of that
point that's also interesting one day
I'm gonna do this all graphically
because I think that might not be
sinking in properly the derivative of
cosine of X is minus sine of X these are
good to memorize though because you'll
be able to recall it quickly on the test
and then use it and then finally the
derivative of tan of X is equal to one
over cosine squared of X which is you
could also write as the secant squared
of X you might want to memorize these
now and and and actually I encourage you
to explore these things I encourage you
to graph each of these functions graph a
function graph is derivative and
look at them and and and really
intuitively understand why the
derivative function actually does
describe the slope of the of the
original function and actually I'll
probably do a presentation on that but
I'm almost out of time in this
presentation so just memorize these and
memorize the derivative e to the X is e
to the X and the natural log of X is 1
over X and in the next presentation
we're gonna start mixing and matching
all of these functions and we can use
the product and chain rule on them to
solve kind of arbitrarily complex
derivatives it'll probably between what
we've just seen we could probably solve
95% of the derivative problems you'll
see on say the calculus AP test I'll see
you the next presentation